Execute order 66 yes Lord Sidious.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
Execute order 66. this is going to be my
Clone Wars season 7 episode 11 video
there were a ton of Easter eggs they
even played some footage directly from
Revenge of the Sith so we'll break it
all down if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen the episode yet will do top 10
and Easter eggs as we go along so
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode in the music at the beginning
the title of the episode shattered is a
reference to the shattering of the Jedi
Order by the Emperor when he execute
order 66 activating all the control
chips in the clones brains forcing them
to hunt down and kill the Jedi because
they're hunting down ahsoka and Darth
Maul during the episode they just
confirms that it's not just the
currently active Jedi that they're going
after it's pretty much any known force
user but the Emperor didn't kill all
force users I'll explain that in a
second some young links he captured and
turned into his Inquisitor division but
that was a little bit different they
cover some of that during the Jedi
fallen order of video game 2 the music
is haunting because everyone watching
the episode knows what's getting ready
to happen we know about order 66 so the
music is just there to instill the sense
of dread and impending doom even through
the first couple minutes of the episode
every time you see Darth Maul he just
senses that something is in the air he
just senses the dark side of the force
is getting so overwhelming that he knows
something terrible is about to happen
and he's just waiting for a doll go down
9 ahsoka and poke at an imprisoned Darth
Maul and the last remaining special
Mandalorian Jedi prison for transport
back to the Jedi Temple it's a reference
to the Jedi Mandalorian Wars thousands
of years ago the reference her sister
duchess satine again saying that she had
all the anti jedi weapons dismantled or
outlawed a long time ago this is pretty
much the last remaining relic from that
era but because we know the Mandalorians
Great Purge is getting ready to happen
we know that there's a whole bunch of
other Mandalorian relics that the Empire
is going to raid pretty soon
when ahsoka references boca tan becoming
the new leader of the Mandalorians
that's actually a reference to what's
going to happen on Star Wars rebels in a
couple years down the timeline where she
becomes the leader of her people they
reunite and Sabine wrens  going to give her
the dark saber right now the dark saber
is actually still on Dathomir left there
by Darth Maul it will show up next on
Star Wars rebels number eight the Jedi
Council moves against Palpatine with the
war technically over they have that
scene where mace Windu and Yoda the rest
of the council discuss how they're
worried Palpatine isn't  going to give back
his emergency powers he was granted by
the Senate during Revenge of the Sith an
attack of the clones they sort of
addressed this where he's slowly bit by
bit convinces the Senate to grant him
more and more decision-making power and
autonomy then finally during Revenge of
the Sith
after Anakin turns to the dark side
after they execute order 66 he declares
the Republic's going to become a new
Galactic Empire officially naming
himself Emperor then they eventually
disband the Senate entirely before the
events of a new hope they sort of
referenced that during episode four this
meeting between mace windu Yoda ahsoka
the Jedi Council is right before mace
windu talks to Anakin about Palpatine
being a Sith Lord than them showing up
ready for that big fight they also
remind you a little bit about where you
are in the timeline of Revenge of the
Sith when mace windu tells us oka that
they've located Grievous on Utapau so
it's right before this big obi-wan fight
number seven you all probably noticed
how the republic battleship looks even
more like a classic Star Destroyer the
way that they filmed it during the
episode all the men are starting to look
more like Imperials the uniforms look
much more classic Star Wars the way they
filmed the bridge of the battleship with
the pits and the men looking up Darth
Maul's prison cell looks exactly like
Leia's prison cell from the Death Star
in a new hope remember at the end of
Revenge of the Sith they sort of tease
the construction of the Death Star
that's been happening for a while when
the movie picks up because they have
most of the bones of it created even all
the clone troopers start acting more
like and looking like the classic
stormtroopers but here's the thing
actually big easter egg about the
classic Star Wars films originally
George Lucas had the idea that the
stormtroopers in the original movies
were all supposed to be clones but then
that slowly changed because the clones
all started to die from old age being
replaced by regular people during the
events of the original trilogy like when
we see Rex der
Star Wars rebels he's actually kind of
an old man so most of the stormtroopers
buy a new hope Empire Strikes Back and
Return of the Jedi
Iran chooses regular people that have
been conscripted into the Empire six
ahsoka and Rex's last conversation
before Anakin turns to the dark side so
they're standing here on the bridge they
have this really deep conversation about
how the Jedi aren't supposed to be
soldiers but ahsoka has spent her entire
life as a soldier that's just a
reference to them creating her for the
Clone Wars series and how she began as a
pad one under Anakin's tutelage in the
first season Dave Filoni actually said
that he and George Lucas actually had
conversations about almost retconning
her into Episode two attack of the
clones as this young girl here but
because the ages didn't work out with a
timeline they didn't wind up doing it
just because ahsoka
at this point needed to be way older
Commander Rex gets all philosophical
about the clones reminding us that the
clones are tired of the war they're
ready to retire but they know that Darth
Sidious manipulated everything from the
start the whole war and without the war
and Palpatine creating them they
wouldn't even exist so is this really
weird moral conundrum on their part
where they're happy to be alive they
want to lead normal productive lives in
the galaxy but they were created for
this really evil purpose then five
things take a turn for the worst
Anakin finally turns to the dark side
they play a clip directly from Revenge
of the Sith this scene when mace windu
is about ready to kill Palpatine and
Anakin chops his arm off allowing
Palpatine to force lightning him out the
window
creating a thousand fan theories about
how he's secretly survived because we
never saw a body even samuel l.jackson
who loves being in these giant franchise
movies still makes jokes about how mace
windu is still alive
so when ahsoka is hearing Anakin's in
the emperor's voice Mace Windu's voice
everyone crying out through the force
it's Hayden Christensen's voice not matt
Lanter voice who does the voice of
Anakin on the Clone Wars series it's Ian
McDiarmid who does the emperor in the
live-action movies it's samuel l.jackson
doing the voice of mace windu because
they have all these characters on the
Clone Wars but it's different voice over
actors playing the characters but it's
all because they literally just copy
pasted this entire clip from Revenge of
the Sith into the episode ahsoka is
clearly shaken doesn't totally
understand what happened she's a little
confused she just knows something
haribol went down and it's also a bit of
a reference to Obi Wan's reaction to the
first Death Star destroying Alderaan
when he senses all their deaths in the
force without really understanding what
just happened then for it all goes down
Palpatine execute order 66 activating
all the clones commander Rex looks like
he tries to fight it for a second he
even kills the other two troopers before
they're able to get ahsoka warns her
about fives so that she can learn about
the control chips but then all the
clones open up on her including Rex he
eventually succumbs to the chip it's
pretty heartbreaking to see him turn on
her right after this deep talk they just
had in knowing how long they've been
friends and how all the clones in this
previous episode respected her so much
that they painted their helmets orange
to look just like her face then on a
dime they all turned it just shows you
how deep the programming and those
control chips goes so three ahsoka is
forced to free Darth Maul and ask him
for help to create a diversion
he's totally jazzed up and explains his
part in all this he was never really
privy to the exact plans he only knew
that Palpatine had a plot to kill the
Jedi he didn't know about the clones
until it was all going down in the
moment like I said through the episode
you could just see his eyes shifting
around as he's sensing this all getting
ready to happen through the force so
when ahsoka tells him to go create some
chaos it's what you're good at and he
asks her to give him a fighting chance
he's asking her to give him one of her
lightsabers and of course she's like oh
hell no I'm not giving you one of these
lightsabers he doesn't really need it
because number two he just tears through
all those clone troopers just like Darth
Vader tearing through the rebels at the
end of rogue one the scene of him
running that gauntlet ripping them apart
savagely is meant to be a direct
reference to this Darth Vader scene
It's a great scene and a good example of
how powerful the dark side can be even
though Darth Vader is way way more
powerful than Darth Maul the funny
parallel you guys have also probably
realized between the two of them though
is that by the time of this Darth Vader
scene he also has almost as many
cybernetic body part replacements as
darth maul darth maul had been sliced in
half so his entire lower half is
mechanical but anakin also has a lot of
his body parts replaced with sith
technology the number one obviously
ahsoka is able to remove Rex's control
chip paying off the Star Wars rebels
seen in the future when Rex talks about
why he didn't wind up killing ahsoka or
any of the other Jedi during order 66
he said his control chip was removed and
then they just give us that scene here
then he reveals the true extent of
Palpatine's plan the entire Grand Army
is now hunting down the Jedi all the
clones and is all going to be over very
very quickly
remember the Revenge of the Sith
timeline right when this is happening is
probably when Anakin is on his way to
the Jedi Temple to kill all the
younglings - for this scene they might
reference that in next week's episode
just to make a souca cry a little bit
more then hopefully in the finale
they'll show us his transformation into
Darth Vader in some sort of a Sokka
post-credits scene after the ending of
revenge a--this is just to show us where
she went into hiding next is sort of tee
up the Mandalorian season - ahsoka stuff
if you haven't seen any of my videos
ahsoka will be featured on the
Mandalorian season to play by rosario
Dawson live action ahsoka finally big
reminder about what's happening next
week to the Clone Wars finale is
actually going to be on Monday May the
4th because it's Star Wars day and
they're also  going to drop the first
episode of that special Mandalorian
series so if you don't have Disney Plus
make sure you find a way to watch those
episodes Rick and Morty is also back
this weekend two new episodes so I'll be
doing videos for everything as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see those videos when I post
them every one click here for the
Mandalorian season two teaser trailer
and click here for all my Star Wars
Clone Wars episodes thank you so much
for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight!